The joe rogan experience.
We're good.
All right.
We're live sort of,
sort of loud.
We're,
we're rolling.
We're rolling.
We're rolling dog.
So,
uh,
so we were talking about the game.
We stopped because we figured this is probably good for the podcast,
right?
So Ari finally paid off the debt.
I paid it off in a big way,
man,
in a big way.
Um,
so if you remember,
I,
when we were doing the weight loss challenge,
it was like whoever wins decides the sporting event,
we're all sports fans basically,
you know,
and,
and I said at the time I was like,
let's go see Barcelona.
I think I wanted to see Barcelona play Paris in the,
you know,
some tournament cups.
I'm channel a tournament that they were playing in.
And I was like,
you know,
two of the premier teams and it'd be fun to go to Europe and make already pay
for it,
you know,
so,
so I told him that and he was like,
I'm going to like fucking Malaysia.
He just left.
So I never heard from him again.
Then four months later,
you know how it all it all played out.
So when he got back he was getting fucking slam by people because he was
supposed to pay up this bet,
you know,
and people were destroying him,
you know that I mean online,
they were just like,
well chill,
you're a piece of shit.
Probably worse than that.
But um,
anyways,
once we got it,
we got to like hanging out.
Once we did the sober October thing,
um,
he was just like right before that actually,
I think he was like [inaudible],
which means like,
what do you want to do?
Right?
And I go,
well,
how about
I go,
uh,
he was like,
you know,
you picked the event.
I go,
I'm a big college football fan.
Let's go to the national championship game.
And I remember,
uh,
in 20,
at the end of 2013 season 2014,
Fsu and Auburn played in the rose bowl out here and Bertrand Fsu alum,
I'm a big FSU fan.
I was like,
let's go to the game.
And I remember that we met,
uh,
it was like we kind of somebody who had student,
cause they both always in the national championship,
they allow students to go to the game for pretty expensive,
much less than the general public can go forward.
In other words there because you want students have the ability to go to see
their school play.
So we got like student tickets for,
I think they were three 50 each and that's pretty expensive,
you know,
especially for a student.
But I remember Burt treated me.
He,
he bought the ticket from me and we went to that,
to that game and he left that fucking halftime of the national championship
game.
Why'd he leave?
He was,
I'm tired.
We going to see the kids who've been drinking.
He left.
There was one of the basket was left you there?
We were sitting in separate sections,
but I was like,
are you fucking,
I was like texting him and he was like,
so you were by yourself and he was by himself?
Yeah.
He knew more people at the game because a lot of his friends that he went to
school with were at the game too.
But I'm like,
you're gone.
Did you just see the kickoff return that just the,
the,
the lead just like swung.
And he was like,
I'm at home.
And I was like,
all right.
So all right,
psycho.
So weird.
I,
I gave him shit for it.
I still give him shit for it,
but it ended up being just this amazing finish.
So anyways,
when I tell Ari I want to go to this,
I'm kind of thinking that's the ballpark.
Like,
cause that's the only experience I have.
So the games in Atlanta,
he buys tickets and I'm like,
I go,
you're not flying me coach.
You know that.
He's like,
no,
you're the champ.
You give first bird work,
his coach,
he goes on work as coaches,
all good.
It must be bill extension.
Oh cool.
But burden ended up going from somewhere else.
So anyways,
he bought the ticket,
he got an Airbnb,
a really nice house,
you know,
for a few days in Atlanta.
And then it's uh,
you know,
it's the big thing is game day.
I'm thinking like,
oh that's cool that you got these tickets and you got,
you know,
but I think it's like reasonable and then we get to this state,
I mean it was a total fucking disaster to get in because Trump went to the game,
so it was raining,
it was wet secret service everywhere to our lines to get into the venue and I
paid a guy,
a security guy,
100 bucks to walk us through the line,
which is,
which was almost impossible because it was so packed,
but I don't,
he just started walking us through the line like in front of people.
People were yelling at the security guy,
which was like so uncomfortable.
He's like a young black kid and like old white people,
where the fuck are you doing?
He's like,
I'm security.
And they're like,
you're not just security you piece of shit like right to is right in front of
us.
I was like,
God damn.
Like I just have never seen someone flip out like that.
What we were doing was highly unethical.
We shouldn't have done it,
but like we just weren't going to wait in that line.
And then Burt,
of course Burt in a crowd like that,
he's like,
it's okay,
I'm famous.
We're famous guys like yelling that to people,
which is like,
no,
oh absolutely.
He's like,
he's like,
we're everywhere we went,
if we went to a restaurant they would come up and be like,
Hey,
can I get you guys something to drink?
And he'd be like,
do recognize us.
We were like,
they were like,
what was he serious?
I mean I think it's part of his like,
you know,
whatever style.
And then,
and they were like,
I'm sorry.
So part of a joke or part of,
I think he's joking,
he's like halfway in the middle because one time,
one time he was like,
we were famous comedians and the lady was like,
Oh,
I know who you are.
And he was like,
oh,
isn't it awesome being famous guys like shut up.
And he was serious.
I mean,
he's like half serious.
He's like,
but it's like you see him in his element.
It's like him in with crowds is really like,
you realize that he really enjoys it.
Like he really enjoys the large groups.
He enjoys being recognized.
He fucking like sometimes we were walking and people were like,
Hey,
you're the guy,
I've seen you on Facebook.
And he's like,
you want to picture?
And they were like,
okay.
Yeah,
he loves it.
He loves it.
And then we were talking about how like people would say like,
Tom and I were like,
yeah.
And they're like,
hey.
And then they would walk away.
They wouldn't come over to me.
They're like,
hi.
And then they'd walk another way.
But with birth they're like,
hi,
a hug you.
They take the shirt off.
I love,
they love it.
And he's like,
in his glory with it.
It's perfect.
So anyways,
we get through this horrific line into this unbelievable one point $6 billion
stadium that they built in Atlanta.
I mean,
it is,
it's fucking amazing.
It's such a beautiful,
just standalone stadium,
you know,
state of the art.
It's incredible.
We get in there.
Ari got us 50 yard lines of right in the middle,
like 20 rows back.
I'm like,
these are fucking amazing.
Like you couldn't ask for better seats.
It has like some club access for like free booze,
free food,
catered food,
prime rib.
I'm like,
Jesus.
how much did you pay for these tickets?
And he's like,
Oh yeah,
I want to know
$3,500 each.
Whoa.
I was like,
Ari,
are you fucking shit?
And he's like,
how to do it?
To do it?
Oh yeah.
But he fucking spent over 10 grand on tickets for us.
Wow.
Yeah.
Unreal,
man.
That's amazing.
I mean,
those are,
those are great seats,
Dude.
Like those are absolutely amazing seat.
[inaudible].